you say to people who claim that there's
no such thing as biological sex
for example i sent i don't know if you
got a chance to look at the video there
was a professor who said
there is no such thing as biological sex
i'm a historian of medicine and i can
debunk that but then he didn't go on to
debunk it
well i think that that's not correct
that there is such a thing as biological
sense but where we draw the line
is um uh
and where it's been drawn before by uh
scientists and doctors is
pretty shameful and has been revealed to
be false in
in retrospect i think that uh ann as in
my wife ann is in earshot but uh she'll
tell you that back in the 70s when
she was a young woman it was received
scientific wisdom that women's bodies
would fall apart if they were to run a
marathon
how's that and so what is essentially
male and female i think so often is
socially constructed for the benefit of
the
powerful members of of um
of societies and so more often than not
we have to pay attention to
to the socially constructed
aspects so but at the end of the day
we just have to let the chips fall where
they where they may
you